I wish that Starbucks had like the for
dummies menu where it actually tells you
at all these drink names mean I tried
coffee but never Starbucks I don't like
bananas are bogus if that count if I put
a ton of milk in it it'll be okay
standard Starbucks coffee it smells
terrible I usually like the smell of
coffee this one does seem really bitter
to me all right here we go it's smooth
I'll give it that nothing special about
it not for me anyway burn tinder I don't
know how people drink this he's a little
bit more like machine oil and it does
coffee so this looks fun real coffee
drinkers think this is basically dessert
if their coffee in this that's not bad I
get it now it's like a milkshake with
just a little bit of coffee flavor it's
just sugar and probably what God enjoys
every single morning yeah the only
reason that I like this is because it's
barely coffee which I imagine is the
reason why it's so popular good see
people like associating a drink like
this with the basic turn people be like
drinking coffee but you're not drinking
but those basic [ __ ] are clearly onto
something I keep this yeah it sounds
like very far and exciting like oh I'll
have a caramel macchiato doesn't it
started in Seattle like let's drop this
Italian pretense nope this I actually
don't like this is more of an adult
drink would totally rather have the
Frappuccino than the macchiato
this is for indecisive people people who
are like I don't want to drink
straight-up coffee but I also don't want
to have the guilt that comes along with
this one if it was a matter of life and
death and I had to pick a coffee item
from Starbucks I would pick the caramel
macchiato life-or-death oh I don't think
they live up to the hype at all
definitely go back for that property no
I'm not going to saw drinking coffee if
I did go to Starbucks again I would
or these I don't think that their
product is necessarily superior to
anyone elses turn into
[Music]